first of all let me very clear canada's
confidence in russia's reliability is
pretty much nil
they have demonstrated nothing but poor
faith they have precipitated a global
energy crisis a global food crisis
with their illegal invasion of ukraine
and the rest of us have been working
very very hard to try and mitigate those
issues around the world
on grain i can tell you that it's an
issue that canada with a significant
amount of expertise in grain
and grain shipping
has been directly engaged in that with
partners around the world for many many
months now we are optimistic i had a
conversation with
with secretary general guterres of the
united nations just a few weeks ago
about the work that they're doing to
find a way to get this grain that is in
silos in ukraine out uh to places around
the world i was in africa a few months
ago a couple months a
few weeks ago to talk to uh world
leaders there who are extremely
concerned with the uh with the shortage
of grain uh and i highlighted for them
russia's responsibility in uh creating
and precipitating this grain crisis uh
the g7 is working closely with partners
like turkey and others uh to ensure that
we can get that grain out of ukraine and
to places around the world where it's
needed without putting at risk uh
ukraine's sovereignty and protection
that's what we'll be watching very very
closely to make sure that this does not
put ukraine further at risk of being
further invaded and attacked by russia
russia is responsible for this global
food crisis because of the
wrong-headed decision they took to
invade a peaceful neighbor
we are now working very hard to solve it
and i hope for the sake of the global
south and everyone around the world
we're able to solve it